all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started um so today guys
I've just been on I've just been
tweeting a lot lately
I don't know what to tell you I just I
gotta keep you guys updated on on my
tweets
so
first of all
you guys have been photoshopping the
hell out of my face is this what
facetune
does to people like this is my face
I might have a little makeup on from
yesterday not much like you're telling
me this is honest
even if I get even if I get like makeup
and learn to do my makeup like this this
is like an honest
this is like
and then you guys photoshopped me
with a burqa
with a burka and that okay
now I actually kind of appreciate seeing
the different hairstyles I liked this
one this one was my favorite
but I I haven't really been into the
face tune stuff so I'm like
is this what you guys do is this why the
men are screaming cat but like you
cannot tell me this is not a catfish I
would rather have you guys be triggered
by the way I look
then live my life
having people think I look like this
I actually do wear my hair like this
sometimes but I forgot my straightener
on this trip
sad Okay so
what are we talking about today women
will die on the hill of being a shitty
wife we why will we die on this hill so
I had a tweet
I had a tweet and I was just curious all
right
where where is this tweet I said
um
women will die on the hill of wanting to
be shitty wives nothing I say should be
controversial now you know I get some
Flack now and then because I say I don't
really give advice like I'm not here
saying guys this is how you pick a good
girl or women like this is the the
step-by-step plan of how to get not not
but then people will push back on me and
say yes you do and they'll pull up
tweets like this where I say
women will die on the hill of being
shitty wives submit to your husband stay
in shape for your husband sleep with
your husband
quote unquote talk to me when you're
married with kids none of this should be
controversial is this controversial you
guys tell me maybe I'm crazy maybe this
is insane is it crazy do I need a PhD in
marriage
to say
maybe sorry guys my phone keeps falling
maybe you should you know have sex with
your husband and maybe you should stay
in shape and when people can't argue
with you what they'll do is they'll
bring in personal attacks
so they'll be like
well Pearl
you're not married what does that have
to do
with basic things that we can agree on
stay in shape for with stay in shape for
your husband
submit to your husband sleep with your
like this is basic guys and here's the
problem we have is as women we cannot
even oh [__] we cannot even agree on an
Ideal
how are we supposed to as women strive
to be better if we can't even agree with
the ideal wife is
and I had another tweet I said
legit for the men I said lead your
family have sex with your wife stay in
shape for your wife and
it's crazy the men were like yeah
yes we should do that you're right but
the women it's like pulling teeth and I
had another poll that I did just out of
curiosity I said what's harder leading
or following and I think 70 of people I
gotta find the poll said that following
is easier so as women we get to do the
easy thing
73 said following is easier okay so it's
easier to to follow than it is to lead
so the men have to do the hard thing and
they're not complaining about it it's
the women we're like here's the easier
job well
well we don't want to do that and that's
that's the crazy thing it's like I'm not
saying I'm the ideal I I've never in a
million years said that but if we can't
have ideal women that we look up to as
Role Models
um or even ideal women that we can point
to and say that's good
the more lost in society we're lost as
women because we have to argue about
three basic things
and I've spoken to overweight wives
that agree with me where they say yes
I need to be in shape for my husband
this is something I struggle with guys
this isn't to shame people or to to get
on like this isn't to be mean to people
that are not those things but if we
cannot agree on what we're striving for
then
we're just lost as women and it's really
sad it's like this is the problem we get
when we start putting fat chicks as
models because we start telling women
this is the ideal that you should strive
for why
why
no it's not when I was a kid my mom
would put models on the fridge okay and
I think anyone from 10 years ago gets my
mom in her right mind did not think that
she looked like those models she did not
in her right mind think she was ever
going to be those models but having an
ideal to strive for is a good thing for
a man to look up to Elon Musk and say I
want to be as good of a businessman as
him is a good thing even if he never in
a million years will be even as close to
Elon Musk or
Bill Gates or whatever great businessman
or even if you get a guy on freaking
steroids that's gen I'm not please do
not clip me saying that I I'm Pro
steroids anti but even even if you say
oh he cheated like whatever it's like
that's still the ideal
and
we will get nowhere in society if we
don't have Heroes if we don't have
people we can look up to and we don't
have ideals and it's like why do women
want to die on the hill of being a bad
wife like why it's okay to say I'm not
perfect it's okay to say I need to
improve in these areas but we cannot
improve as women if we can never even
identify problems and that's where I'm
at
with content it's like you can't even
identify this as a problem how are we
supposed to come up with Solutions if we
as women can't say you know what maybe
we need to work on our submissiveness
maybe as a group we're not doing the
best if we don't say you know what maybe
we're kind of fat maybe we need to get
in better shape you know what maybe we
just need to have sex with our husbands
you know what I maybe call me crazy
and this is what they'll do if they
don't have an argument they'll say well
you're not married I need your life
experience
guys like that's like okay that imagine
imagine there's an obese person walking
around at the gym and I say you know
what I think that person is fat and
should lose weight and then they come
back to what but
where's your PhD in nutrition well
you know what
I I think I think he's I think he's
pretty fat well but you need to lose
weight too you know
I might you know I probably could lose
10 pounds but that's pretty fast and
this is the problem we get to as a
society all right we can't even identify
what's wrong without going back and
forth we can't even set like I was on
whatever podcast last night
I could not say hey
promiscuity
leads
to negative consequences for women women
one in three women of an STD one in
three women
um have had an abortion ninety percent
of women have been on birth control were
on antidepressants more than ever before
this isn't working out for us and like
they're the first reaction
well but you can still have a happy
relationship don't judge no
like why do we need to put in this fluff
in this nonsense no it's not good
well aren't you're not a virgin
yeah I'm not and I could say
in all honesty
as women our lives would probably be
better if when we were younger we just
got married young and waited till we
were married and
I think that's honest but older women
want and even married women will want to
be dishonest to you because they don't
want to look in the mirror
and see that they're not really the best
wives in all honesty very few women
actually submit to their husband it's
rare
it is rare I I would say the majority of
women wear the pants in their
relationship I would say very few women
we have really learned how to be a
submissive wife
very few of us have even have even seen
it so
you know
call me crazy but women will literally
die
on the hill of being a shitty wife
instead of saying you know what these
are areas we can improve so you know
what ladies for the women that want to
be wives and actually want to improve
follow my wife's School
there's episodes coming out soon
yeah anyways like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell I'll talk to you next
time